Hi, I'm Max and a worker's assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that angle in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great buy for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the story has reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal
大家好，我是Max，是西约克郡学习障碍服务中心的一名助理心理学家。和大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是考取临床心理学博士学位。怀着这个目标，我开始研究相关的书籍，看看哪些能对我有所帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安（Marianne）的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），并决定买下它，这对我的职业旅程大有裨益。我觉得玛丽安的书内容非常丰富，见解深刻。我特别喜欢书中传达的理念，它让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美无缺，只要你具备良好的人际交往
skills, such as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, nor so those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and made me want to work in that field one day. In the late 90s, Kavanaugh was one of the biggest pop stars in the UK. But behind the charts and the spotlight, something very different was happening. Today, we're talking about the psychology of fame, addiction, and what it actually takes to rebuild your life when the spotlight fades. If you find it helpful, please like and subscribe for more.
能力，比如同情心和共情能力，你就一定能成功。我强烈向所有有志于成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，也推荐给那些想更多了解临床心理学领域、并希望有朝一日能投身该领域的人。90年代末，卡瓦纳（Kavana）是英国最红的流行歌星之一。但在排行榜和聚光灯背后，却发生着截然不同的事情。今天，我们将探讨名声与成瘾的心理学，以及当聚光灯褪去后，重建生活究竟需要付出什么。如果你觉得有帮助，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。
Welcome along to Psychology Actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm joined here today by Anthony Kavana. Kavana. Hi. Thank you for having me. Finally we meet. We do. Thank you for being here.
欢迎来到《心理学其实》（Psychology Actually）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，今天和我在一起的是安东尼·卡瓦纳（Anthony Kavana）。卡瓦纳，你好。谢谢你邀请我。我们终于见面了。是的。谢谢你能来。
So if people are tuning in and they're like, who is Kavana? Could you tell us a little bit about you and your background? Sure. Well, some people might remember me or know me as Kavanaugh the 90s pop teen, idol, singer. Heart throb. Heart throb. Yeah, heartthrob. and you know I had a string of hits in the late 90s
那么，如果听众朋友们想知道卡瓦纳是谁，你能简单介绍一下你自己和你的背景吗？当然。有些人可能还记得我，或者知道我是90年代的流行青少年偶像、歌手。万人迷。万人迷。对，万人迷。你知道，我在90年代末有一连串的热门歌曲。
I Can Make You Feel Good was the big one that kind of launched me Smash its award poll winner best male artists may I say as well well done dressed as Superman that day and yeah and so that was my that's my background and then kind of disappeared for quite some time I moved to to the States came back and tried to resurrect my career in bits here and there. And now, well, it's all in the book.
《I Can Make You Feel Good》是让我一举成名的那首歌，它赢得了最佳男艺人奖，顺便说一下，那天我还打扮成了超人，干得漂亮。这就是我的背景，后来我消失了一段时间，去了美国，回来后又断断续续地尝试重振事业。现在，好吧，一切都在书里了。
But yeah, I'm kind of, I've written a book myself. And yeah, I'm really pleased with the reaction. So we've got pop scars. Pop scars. It's a little play on words. Yeah. A memoir on fame addiction, the Dark Side of 90s pop by Anthony Kavanaugh, because your actual name is not Kavanaugh, it's Anthony Kavana.
但我确实写了一本书。我对读者的反应感到非常高兴。书名是《流行伤痕》（Pop Scars）。这是一个双关语。是的，这是一本关于名声、成瘾以及90年代流行音乐阴暗面的回忆录，作者是安东尼·卡瓦纳，因为你的真名不是卡瓦纳，而是安东尼·卡瓦纳（Anthony Kavana）。
Yes, that name is given to me. And also I just want to say, with the subtitle of the book, it was kind of decided quite quick. And, you know, as a first time author, you're so kind of pleased to have a book deal. It doesn't happen overnight. You know, I mean, this was 10 years of me trying to write this. And then obviously it's about addiction. So they don't really go together trying to write a book when you're in the throes of addiction.
是的，那个名字是别人给我的。另外，我还想说，关于书的副标题，当时定得很快。作为一个新人作者，能拿到出版合同已经很开心了，这并非一蹴而就。你知道，我花了10年时间才写完这本书。而且显然，书里写的是关于成瘾的内容，所以当你深陷成瘾泥潭时，写书并不是一件容易的事。
But, you know, it isn't really about the dark side of 90s pop. It's more about, I guess, the dark side of addiction with some 90s pop thrown in. but also survival and silver lining. And it's got a lot of humour as well. I had to write with the humour. Yeah. And we cross paths because I was asked to write a review of your book for the British Psychological Society's magazines.
但它其实并不完全是关于90年代流行音乐的阴暗面。我想，它更多是关于成瘾的阴暗面，其中穿插了一些90年代流行音乐的元素，但也包含了生存和一线希望。书中还有很多幽默的成分。我必须用幽默的方式来写。是的。我们之所以有交集，是因为我受邀为英国心理学会的杂志撰写你的书评。
Yeah, which was so cool when that came in. I was like, yes, I totally want to do this. And I must say as well, Marianne, I have been dining out on one of your quotes, which was, this deserves to be a Netflix series. Yeah. And by the way, I can't give too much away, but let's just say
是的，当时收到邀请时太酷了。我当时想，太棒了，我一定要写。而且玛丽安，我必须说，我一直在引用你的一句评价，那就是“这本书值得被拍成Netflix剧集”。是的。顺便说一下，我不能透露太多，但只能说
there's stuff going on in that department. Okay, that's very exciting. But, yeah, I'd messaged you and I said, I'm reading your book and I'm writing it and you'd said, please let me know when it's live. So that's how we cross past. And you very kindly said you'd come on the podcast, so thank you.
那个项目已经在推进中了。好的，那太令人兴奋了。不过，我当时给你发了信息，说我正在读你的书并写书评，你说“书上线了请告诉我”。这就是我们产生交集的方式。你非常友好地答应来参加我的播客，所以谢谢你。
But when I was kind of reading the book and seeing some of the reviews, it was, people were saying, well, it's hilarious. And actually, as a qualified psychologist, I read it and I just felt it's not really funny funny like it's it's painful it felt
但在阅读这本书并看到一些评论时，人们说它“非常搞笑”。实际上，作为一名合格的心理学家，我读完后觉得它并不好笑，而是感到痛苦。它感觉
it felt tricky like I'm a mother as well and you know we're not a million miles away I think you're a few years older than me I just really I'm really worried for you and everything you've been through I found it painful
它感觉很棘手，我也是一位母亲，你知道，我们年纪相差不大，我想你比我大几岁。我真的为你感到担心，为你所经历的一切感到难过。我觉得很痛苦。
even some of the things that happened that were more headliney you know some of the things that went wrong I didn't find it hilarious, hilarious. I was just worried for you, Anthony. Right. Well, thank you, Marian. I do appreciate that.
即使是书中那些更具新闻头条性质的事情，那些出错的事情，我也不觉得好笑。我只是为你感到担心，安东尼。好的。好吧，谢谢你，玛丽安。我真的很感激。
I think, you know, I wanted to write it in a, I could never have written this without the length of sobriety that I've got now, you know, recover and it took me a long time to get sober, you know, many failed attempts, many, you know, many
我想，你知道，我之所以能写这本书，是因为我现在已经保持了很长一段时间的清醒。你知道，康复过程，我花了很长时间才戒掉酒瘾，经历过很多次失败的尝试，很多次
rock bottoms, which is kind of that term is used quite a lot, rock bottom, you know, but I had quite a few and you're not ready until you're ready. But I've always had humour in my life. There's no doubt about it. I'm from an Irish background family, northern on my mum's side. So you can imagine that mix. You know, we've always seen the kind of the humour and stuff. And this, I was adamant. I didn't want to write a pity memoir. And, you know, I, I don't want to say, I'm funny because you can't call yourself funny. But life is, life can be tragic and comedy as well at the
跌入谷底——“跌入谷底”这个词用得很多，你知道，但我经历过好几次，而且除非你准备好了，否则你永远不会真正准备好。但我生活中一直不乏幽默感。毫无疑问，我来自一个爱尔兰背景的家庭，我母亲那边是北方的。所以你可以想象那种混合。你知道，我们总是能看到幽默的一面。我当时很坚决，不想写一本博取同情的书。你知道，我不想说“我很幽默”，因为你不能自称幽默。但生活既可以是悲剧，也可以是喜剧，
same time. So it wasn't forced how I wrote it. I didn't even know some things would land to be funner. So I guess different people have interpreted it different ways. So I appreciate that because it was painful at times. It's only by going back can I write it like that, you know, but I didn't want to, it was not a gut to get the violins out kind of thing. Yeah. Okay. Thank you. Let's think a little bit then because I know that you had your first ever job that was working at McDonald's. Yes. And then, were you fired from that?
同时存在。所以我的写作并不是刻意的。我甚至不知道有些地方会被解读得那么好笑。所以我想不同的人有不同的解读。我很感激这一点，因为写作过程有时确实很痛苦。只有回首往事，我才能那样写出来，你知道，但我不想，我不想表现得像是在卖惨。是的。好的。谢谢。那我们来聊聊，我知道你的第一份工作是在麦当劳。是的。后来，你被解雇了吗？
What happened there? And then you're saying, near a pop star. That's quite the growth, isn't it? Quite the change. Yeah. Yeah. Well, I've just come back from Manchester.
发生了什么？然后你说，你成了流行歌星。这成长跨度很大，不是吗？变化很大。是的。是的。好吧，我刚从曼彻斯特回来。
And, um, because, you know, my mum's there, um, which you might talk about a bit later. But, um, I just walk past that very at McDonald's. It's on Oxford, Oxford Road. And I thought,
而且，嗯，因为我妈妈在那里，我们稍后可能会谈到。但是，我刚才路过那家麦当劳。它在牛津路（Oxford Road）上。我想，
blimey, like, you know, I remember, I remember working there. I just left school. I didn't have many qualifications. I was dreaming of being a pop singer, to be honest. You know, I wanted to get into music. I was musical.
天哪，你知道，我记得我在那里工作过。我刚离开学校，没什么学历。老实说，我当时梦想成为一名流行歌手。你知道，我想进入音乐界。我有音乐天赋。
I could play the piano and sing a little bit privately. I was never a big show-off singing. So I just got a job there to make ends meet. But yeah, I did get fired, which is a silver lining. As, you know, we look back and because if I wouldn't, I might now be area manager. Nothing wrong with that, but I wouldn't have used my talents I was given. Yeah, they have what's called.
我会弹钢琴，私下里也会唱一点。我从来不是那种爱炫耀的歌手。所以我只是找了份工作来维持生计。但确实，我被解雇了，这算是一种“塞翁失马”。正如你所知，我们回首往事时会发现，如果我不被解雇，我现在可能已经是区域经理了。那份工作没什么不好，但我可能就不会发挥我被赋予的天赋了。是的，他们有一种叫
the clean food bin. So when the food goes lukewarm, it goes into a clean bin, right? It's still wrapped up. There's no dirt in there. And I helped myself to a filly of fish one day. And I got caught. And that was forbidden.
“清洁食品箱”。当食物变温时，它会被放进一个干净的箱子里，对吧？它还是包装好的。里面没有脏东西。有一天我拿了一个麦香鱼吃。结果被抓住了。那是被禁止的。
And I got fired. So that's how the book opens with that little. No, it doesn't open with that. It doesn't quite open there. No, there's a cliff hango as it opens later. Yeah.
所以我被解雇了。书的开头就是那个小插曲。不，书不是从那里开始的。开头不太一样。不，有一个悬念，那是后面才写的。是的。
But yeah, that was, that's more the northern kind of coronation street. style where I'm in the, yeah, I'm in McDonald's and I'm a, I get fired. Yeah. Well, it all worked out initially. Well, were you drinking already at that stage? Or did that come later? No, I wasn't.
但那确实更有北方《加冕街》（Coronation Street）的风格，我在麦当劳，然后我被解雇了。是的。好吧，起初一切都很顺利。那么，你当时已经开始喝酒了吗？还是后来才开始的？没有，我没有。
I mean, I was drinking, but God, I mean, it's only like every teenage, you know, kid in, in, my friends were, you know, like we'd go, the night that I meet, the manager that that changes my life. We were on a bit of a pub crawl, you know, and that was the usual, you know, it's like you get to an age, I think, I think I was 16, well, I was 16,
我的意思是，我确实喝过酒，但天哪，那就像每个十几岁的孩子一样，你知道，我的朋友们，我们去……我遇到那个改变我人生的经理的那天晚上，我们正在进行酒吧巡游，你知道，那是很平常的事，你知道，当你到了那个年纪，我想我当时16岁，嗯，我16岁，
and you'd just go for a couple of pints on a Saturday night. You know, you didn't really go to nightclubs. I think Friday nights, I had my friends round from school, and we drink cider in the bedroom, we'd play our tapes, you know, we play our pop music, and smoke a few sigs out the window,
周六晚上你会去喝几杯啤酒。你知道，我们其实不去夜店。我想周五晚上，我会叫学校的朋友来家里，我们在卧室里喝苹果酒，放我们的磁带，你知道，放我们的流行音乐，从窗户抽几根烟，
that kind of thing. But no, I mean, in those early days, there was no issue at all with alcohol. The normal limits. You could kind of take it or leave it. And, you know, of course, it's progressive, as I now understand. But, no, there was no issue at all at that point. No. Yeah.
就是那种事。但没有，在早期，酒精根本不是问题。在正常范围内。你可以喝也可以不喝。而且，你知道，正如我现在所理解的，它是渐进的。但没有，在那一点上根本没有问题。没有。是的。
So they were all kind of building you up and kind of waiting for the perfect time to launch you. And then ultimately it happened. And what was that like for you? Well, it wasn't overnight as people could, you know, perceive it to be. I was, like I said, we went out one night, me and my friends, and we decided we were going to get into a nightclub. And we tried to, we couldn't get in. And the third one, we were finally allowed in. And it happened to be a gay nightclub.
所以他们都在为你铺路，等待完美的时机让你出道。最终它发生了。那对你来说是什么感觉？嗯，并不像人们想象的那样是一夜成名。就像我说的，有一天晚上，我和朋友们出去，决定去一家夜店。我们试了试，没进去。第三家店，我们终于进去了。那恰好是一家同性恋夜店。
I was in the closet. My best friend was kind of in the closet, although he said he was bisexual. It was the air of swayed and, you know, blur. So that was kind of quite cool. And my cousin, who wasn't gay. And we got into this nightclub and in the car. of this nightclub was this manager who was very well known and I went over to him. You know, you don't have any second guessing in when you're that age.
我当时还在“柜子里”。我最好的朋友也差不多，尽管他说他是双性恋。那是Suede和Blur的时代，所以那感觉很酷。还有我的表弟，他不是同性恋。我们进了那家夜店，在夜店的吧台，站着那位非常有名的经理，我走过去找他。你知道，当你那个年纪时，你不会有任何顾虑。
You know, you kind of walk through it. All right, was so ambitious, but I was very naive. Spoke to him, gave me his business card, went in the next, went in on the Monday to his office with a demo tape that I made and I, he signed me on the Friday. So within a week, I was, I'd lost the job at McDonald's, met him, and then I get assigned to the manager. And then it was 18 months, 18 months of learning how to write songs. He bought me a little studio, a tiny little mobile, you know, recording studio and in my bedroom. And I'd write songs every night. And then I'd go to singing lessons, which I write about,
你知道，你就是直接走过去。好吧，我当时很有野心，但我很天真。和他说了话，他给了我名片，周一我带着我制作的演示磁带去了他的办公室，周五他就签下了我。所以在一周之内，我丢了麦当劳的工作，见到了他，然后被签到了经理旗下。接下来的18个月，是学习如何写歌的18个月。他给我买了一个小工作室，一个放在我卧室里的微型移动录音室。我每天晚上都写歌。然后我去上声乐课，我在书里写到了，
this teacher that was brilliant who I went to see. And, you know, you do a bit of dance moves the career group, you know, he's very slowly. But of course, I wasn't in a boy band. So it was, it was figuring out how, how that would work just on my own, you know. And you just, I got impatient. I was like, when is it going to happen? When is it going to happen? But he knew what he was doing because all the labels, because he was such a, it had so much
那位老师非常棒。而且，你知道，你还要做一些舞蹈动作，你知道，他非常缓慢地进行。当然，我不是在一个男子组合里。所以，我必须自己摸索如何以个人身份运作。我当时很没耐心。我心想，什么时候才能成功？什么时候才能成功？但他知道自己在做什么，因为所有的唱片公司，因为他有那么多的
success, the labels, so we got a bidding war and then we signed to Virgin Records. And that's when it, so 18 months later is when it really took off. And I'll always remember him saying, You know, enjoy this time of preparation because once it starts, your feet won't touch the ground. And he was right. Yeah. So I was 18 then when it starts. That's a lot of change.
成功经验，唱片公司之间爆发了竞标战，然后我们签了维珍唱片（Virgin Records）。那就是一切真正起飞的时候。我永远记得他说：“享受这段准备时光吧，因为一旦开始，你就再也停不下来了。”他是对的。是的，那时我18岁。那真是巨大的变化。
And so we're talking about 1995, 1996 sort of time, are we? Yeah, 94 when I signed, 96 when the first single came out. So, yeah, 18 months, two years. Yeah. What a lot of change. And what is that like then? So I know now, obviously with social media, things are a little bit different. But then, you know, what was it like the first time you got recognized?
所以我们谈论的是1995年、1996年左右的时间，对吗？是的，94年签约，96年第一首单曲发行。所以，是的，18个月，两年。是的，巨大的变化。那感觉如何？我知道现在有了社交媒体，情况有点不同。但在当时，你第一次被认出来是什么感觉？
Wow. Do you know what? I remember. I was on the train to St. Ives to see my sister and brother-in-law because they lived there. And it wasn't that I was recognised, but they must have had the radio on the train. Or maybe I had my little Walkman, you know, you could get your radio on. And they played my first single on Radio One. That must have been amazing. Yeah, it wasn't, I can be, I think, it was a song called Crazy Chance. And I wanted to tell everyone in the carriage,
哇。你知道吗？我记得。我在去圣艾夫斯（St. Ives）看望我姐姐和姐夫的火车上，因为他们住在那里。并不是我被认出来了，但火车上一定在放广播。或者可能我戴着我的小随身听，你知道，你可以听广播。他们在Radio One上播放了我的第一首单曲。那一定很棒。是的，那不是……我想，那首歌叫《Crazy Chance》。我想告诉车厢里的每个人，
I was like, I want the radio, you know, so I remember that very first moment. But the recognised thing, it happens slowly, but surely, I mean, I was doing under 18's nightclubs. I write about that in the book and some of those, you know. I'm surprised I wasn't there, frankly. You may have been, did you have a high ponytail in the shell suit? Probably.
我当时想，那是我的歌，你知道，所以我记得那个最初的时刻。但“被认出来”这件事，是缓慢但肯定地发生的。我的意思是，我当时在做未成年人夜店的演出。我在书里写到了那些经历。坦白说，我很惊讶我当时不在场。你可能在场，你当时是不是扎着高马尾，穿着运动套装？可能吧。
Probably. Probably. Probably. And, you know, that was, uh, so it was gradual. And then suddenly you do start being recognised. You know, I think my first TV appearance was live and kicking at like 8, 8 o'clock in the morning, singing live. And that's when it starts to it. That's when you go in the supermarket or Azda with your mum, like I always used to.
可能吧。可能吧。可能吧。而且，你知道，那是……所以这是循序渐进的。然后突然间，你开始被认出来了。你知道，我想我第一次上电视是在《Live & Kicking》节目，早上8点，现场演唱。那就是一切开始的时候。那就是当你和妈妈去超市或Asda时，像我以前常做的那样。
I'd come home and do the normal stuff. And then you see, oh, bloody out. But my mother was always telling people I was going to be famous. You know, she was well known in the area, Rita, my mum. And then, you know, I'd walk up the last. let Moston Lane where I lived. And there'd be a picture of me in the Butchers, which he'd have given like a signed picture or something.
我回家做正常的事情。然后你看到，哦，天哪。但我妈妈总是告诉别人我会出名。你知道，她在当地很有名，丽塔，我妈妈。然后，你知道，我走在莫斯顿巷（Moston Lane），我住的地方。肉铺里会有我的照片，她会给他们一张签名照什么的。
You know what I mean? So, yeah, it was slow. But you just kind of slowly get used to it, you know? Yeah. There was no immediate thing. Yeah. And, you know, I was 14-ish when your big song came out. Right.
你知道我的意思吗？所以，是的，很慢。但你只是慢慢习惯了，你知道吗？是的。没有那种突如其来的感觉。是的。而且，你知道，你的大热单曲出来时，我大概14岁左右。对。
I can make you feel good. I think so. And I bought it. I bought the single. I was a big fan. Thank you. But what I didn't know and what I think you weren't allowed to talk about was that you were gay.
《I Can Make You Feel Good》。我想是这样。我买了那张单曲。我是你的忠实粉丝。谢谢。但我不知道的是，而且我认为当时不允许谈论的是，你是同性恋。
Yeah. And that must have been incredibly difficult to be having all this internal stuff going on for you. But having to, I guess, act. Were you encouraged to act straight in the media? No. No. There was no discussion about my sexuality. The manager knew I was gay.
是的。那一定非常困难，内心承受着这一切，却不得不，我想，去演戏。媒体有没有鼓励你表现得像个直男？没有。没有。关于我的性取向没有任何讨论。经理知道我是同性恋。
I never said I was gay, but he knew. I never came out to anyone so I was I was hiding it from myself I'd had no you know no real experience I suppose with anyone my age of anything like that of the same sex but because my dream had come true
我从未说过我是同性恋，但他知道。我从未向任何人出柜，所以我对自己也隐瞒着。我没有任何，你知道，和同龄人有过任何那种同性经历，但因为我的梦想成真了
I sacrificed that this was all I'd ever dreamed of so that can go on the backburner I'll meet someone eventually I don't need to worry about that you know so I just and I'd got this new identity, you see. I'd become this name Kavanaugh. So I was no longer Anthony.
我牺牲了这一切，因为这是我一直以来的梦想，所以其他事情都可以先放一放。我迟早会遇到某个人，我不需要担心那个，你知道吧。所以我只是……而且我已经有了这个新的身份，你明白吗。我已经变成了“卡瓦纳”这个名字。所以我不再是安东尼了。
So I took the identity on. I see. It's a little bit like a mask, like a costume you try on. So when you're Kavanaugh, I do these sorts of things and say these sorts of things and go and sing on TV. Actually, when I'm Anthony, I'll be hanging out with my mum and my mates. And that's like a split. Yeah, absolutely. And I was actually quite happy to take on that identity because I was quite a shy kid.
所以我接受了这个身份。我明白。这有点像面具，像你试穿的戏服。所以当你成为卡瓦纳时，我会做这些事，说这些话，去电视上唱歌。实际上，当我做回安东尼时，我会和妈妈还有朋友们待在一起。那就像是一种分裂。是的，绝对是。而且我其实很乐意接受那个身份，因为我小时候很害羞。
and obviously, you know, there's a bit of bullying at school and stuff like that because I did look, people used to say is that a boy or a girl because I had the long hair. I was a bit, these long eyelashes is and I was a bit chubbier, a bit younger. So once I'd lost the way, I got my hair cut, I changed my name, or they changed my name. And so I became this new identity. So I kind of took cues from other pop singers, male, my age. and they were all a bit cheeky chippy, chippy. I suppose in the boy band, you'd have different identities, wouldn't you?
显然，你知道，在学校里会受到一些欺凌之类的，因为我的长相，人们常说“那是男孩还是女孩”，因为我留着长发。我有点……长睫毛，而且我当时胖一点，年纪小一点。所以一旦我瘦下来，剪了头发，改了名字，或者说他们帮我改了名字。我就变成了这个新身份。所以我从其他和我同龄的男流行歌手身上借鉴了一些东西。他们都有点厚脸皮、调皮。我想在男子乐队里，你会有不同的身份，对吧？
You'd have the more serious one, you'd have the laddie one, you'd have the more sensitive one. I was definitely the more sensitive one, but because I was on my own, I thought I better just become all of them rolled into one. So I was very much still myself, but I did put on a bit of an act, like the kind of buy next door kind of thing. That's such a lot of pressure there, isn't it? Because you are just one person.
你会有一个更严肃的，一个更爱玩的，一个更敏感的。我绝对是那个更敏感的，但因为我是单飞，我想我最好把自己变成所有这些角色的集合体。所以我本质上还是我自己，但我确实演了一点戏，就像那种“邻家男孩”的感觉。那压力很大，不是吗？因为你毕竟只是一个人。
How can we realistically expect you to be five? Yeah, right. But that's what I wanted, you know. And that's, I assumed I was going to be asked to audition for a boy band when I first started. But no, I was told, no, I think you should be on your own. It's like, well, I'll do anything. Yeah, okay. Yeah.
我们怎么能现实地期望你一个人活成五个人呢？是啊，没错。但这正是我想要的，你知道。而且我当时以为我刚开始时会被要求去参加男子乐队的试镜。但没有，我被告知：“不，我觉得你应该单飞。”我就想，好吧，我什么都愿意做。是的，好吧。是的。
So it went really well. At one stage, I think in the book you said, you'd missed Madonna's call. I mean, that's a sign that things are going quite well, right? Yeah, that was, I had to get that in because, I mean, look. So what happened? Tell us a story. So we, I would, I'd go back to my mum and dads. I was very lucky that I was able to buy them a house quite early on.
所以一切都很顺利。书里有一段提到你错过了麦当娜的电话。我的意思是，那是个事业进展相当顺利的信号，对吧？是的，我必须把它写进去，因为，你看。所以发生了什么？给我们讲讲这个故事。所以我们……我会回到我爸妈家。我很幸运，很早就给他们买了一套房子。
I mean, so, you know, that's mad. We lived in a council house on a council estate. My parents had me quite older. They're in the 40s when they had me. and so you know it was a bit it wasn't really the place to I would get bullied and spotted and stuff like that and I was quite anyway so we got this little small house
我的意思是，你知道，这太疯狂了。我们以前住在政府公屋里。我父母生我时年纪很大了。他们四十多岁才有了我。所以你知道，那地方不太适合……我会被欺负、被指指点点之类的，而且我当时……总之，我们买了这栋小房子。
I would go back there at the weekends if I wasn't working so if I wasn't doing like radio and road shows you weren't being Kavana basically if I wasn't being Kavanaugh I guess yeah I mean it sounds weird talking myself and the other is it third person third person but yeah if I wasn't being the pop singer I'm working or on tour or wherever I would go back to my mum and dad's house because that's where I lived.
如果我不工作，周末我就会回到那里。如果我没在做电台节目或路演，你基本上就不是“卡瓦纳”。如果我没在扮演卡瓦纳，我想是的。我的意思是，用第三人称谈论自己和另一个自己听起来很奇怪，但确实，如果我没在当流行歌手，没在工作或巡演，我就会回到我爸妈家，因为那就是我住的地方。
I didn't buy myself a little flat. I bought a little family home for all of us because I was still quite young and naive. You know, I didn't really know about buying a male. But even part of that, it sounded like that was kind of the management was suggesting maybe where your mum and dad were living wasn't really what pop stars would be doing. So you moved somewhere different, which was problematic as well.
我没有给自己买小公寓。我为我们全家买了一个小家庭住宅，因为我当时还很年轻、很天真。你知道，我真的不懂买房。但即便如此，听起来好像是经纪公司建议说，你爸妈住的地方不太像流行歌星该住的地方。所以你搬到了别处，这也带来了问题。
Yeah, I mean there was two houses. The first one, we did take them out of their area, but still more or less in the same area, but just on a more like a Brookside style, you know, like one of those show homes that you see, like... Bit of a development. Bit of a development, yeah. Funny enough, it's right near where my mum's care home is now.
是的，我的意思是当时有两套房子。第一套，我们确实把他们从原来的社区搬了出来，但还是在同一个区域，只是更像那种“布鲁克赛德”风格的，你知道，就像那种样板房……算是一个开发项目。算是一个开发项目，是的。有趣的是，它就在我妈妈现在住的养老院附近。
So I walk past it, it's funny. So I'd go back there. My best friend Andrew would still come and see me, the one who went in the nightclub with Mith, who had known since I was a kid. And we'd just hang out like normal at the weekends. Like we used to on a Sunday. If I was off, it went straight back into being Antonin.
所以我走过那里时觉得很有趣。所以我以前会回到那里。我最好的朋友安德鲁还会来看我，就是那个和我一起去夜店的米斯，我从小就认识他。周末我们就像普通人一样待在一起。就像我们以前周日做的那样。如果我休息，我就直接变回安东尼。
We must have been really grounding, actually. Oh, it was great, yeah. And we'd play our tapes, and we'd do silly things, and my dad would be downstairs watching his bull's eye, and my mum might be at, bingo, it was dead northern. And I remember this one night, the Nokia rang. You know, you used to be a bit heavier in them days, weren't there? Unknown number.
那一定让你感到很踏实。哦，那太棒了，是的。我们会放磁带，做些傻事，我爸爸会在楼下看他的《靶心》节目，我妈妈可能在玩宾果游戏，那真是太北方了。我记得有一天晚上，诺基亚响了。你知道，那时候手机还挺沉的，对吧？未知号码。
So I'm not answering that. So I'm, who's ringing me on an unknown number? We're a fan. You don't know who it is, you know? I didn't answer it and Andrew was always he started to see my popularity and all these new people in London
所以我没接。我在想，谁用未知号码给我打电话？是粉丝吗？你不知道是谁，对吧？我没接，安德鲁一直……他开始看到我的受欢迎程度，还有我在伦敦认识的那些新朋友。
that were my friends and he's like oh you're always talking on the phone so I was very adamant not to answer anyway pick it up and it's her voice note yeah from Madonna she was with someone that had met at some party a director he told her about me
他们是我的朋友，他就会说：“哦，你总是在打电话。”所以我非常坚持不接电话。总之，我接起来了，是她的语音留言。是的，来自麦当娜。她当时和我在某个派对上认识的人在一起，一个导演，他告诉了她关于我的事。
I don't know what it said but she left a message and she was basically inviting me to a party in London and I've heard all about you you and but you're not there and uh yeah so long sucker she said at the end and then she put the phone down oh now me and andrew used to play like a prayer non-stop in fact at one point i think i write in the book we had a shrine built to madonna right in my bedroom with with candles because it was all
我不知道她说了什么，但她留了言，基本上是邀请我去伦敦参加一个派对，她说：“我听说了很多关于你的事，你……但你不在那儿，呃，好吧，再见啦笨蛋。”她在最后说了这句话，然后挂了电话。哦，我和安德鲁以前不停地放《Like a Prayer》，事实上，我想我在书里写过，我的卧室里甚至建了一个麦当娜的神龛，点着蜡烛，因为那一切……
imagine if you'd answered that but then would you have necessarily believed it had been her well it was definitely her because i found out it was and you couldn't mistake a voice um and i was in manchester she was in london it was 8 o'clock at night it wasn't it wasn't going to work at worked but my God have I like thought and I've been at parties where she's been in the room further like when she was with Guy Richard but I was too nervous to go over
想象一下如果你接了那个电话，但你当时会相信那是她吗？嗯，那绝对是她，因为我后来确认了，你不会认错那个声音。我在曼彻斯特，她在伦敦，当时是晚上8点，那是不可能的。但天哪，我确实想过。我参加过她在场的派对，比如当她和盖·里奇在一起的时候，但我太紧张了，不敢过去。
but yeah maybe one day our paths will cross again you never know but that was wild yeah do you answer your unknown numbers now just in case no I still don't answer the phone at all terrifying I'm answering the phone I don't really like the phone I only text or I met WhatsApp
但也许有一天我们的道路会再次交汇，谁知道呢。但那太疯狂了。你现在会接未知号码的电话吗，以防万一？不，我还是根本不接电话。太可怕了，我接电话……我不太喜欢电话，我只发短信或用WhatsApp。
but no I don't but I did give everyone my pinn't code that night. You know you used to get... For your BBMs? Yeah. You know you could get it from a landline. You could go on a landline phone and get your pin code and listen to your voicemail. Oh, that rings a bell. Yeah. So everyone was listening into your voice note. Oh, I gave the pin code that night to everyone, yeah. I didn't record it. I wish I'd have a doctor phone. Yeah, I didn't have one. Before we continue, it's time for a quick behind the therapy room door moment brought to you by write-up. Who are the practice management system I use in my own clinical practice. One thing that often comes up
但我不接。不过那天晚上我确实把我的PIN码告诉了所有人。你知道以前……为了你的BBM？是的。你知道你可以通过座机获取它。你可以用座机拨号，获取你的PIN码并收听语音信箱。哦，那听起来很耳熟。是的。所以每个人都在听你的语音留言。哦，那天晚上我把PIN码告诉了所有人，是的。我没录下来。我真希望我有那个电话。是的，我没有。在我们继续之前，是时候进行一个简短的“治疗室门后”时刻了，由Write-up为您呈现。他们是我在自己的临床实践中使用的诊所管理系统。有一件事经常出现。
in trauma and addiction work is how important it is for people to feel safe enough to tell their story at their own pace. In therapy, the details of someone's experiences can emerge slowly over time, sometimes across many sessions. But for that work to happen, people actually need to be able to get to their sessions. And when someone is at a vulnerable stage in their recovery, small things like clear appointment reminders, easy communication and reliable scheduling can make a real difference in helping them stay connected to the work. Write-up is trusted by over 50,000 clinicians. If you'd like to try it yourself, you can access a free trial for up to five users using the link in the description.
在创伤和成瘾工作中，人们感到足够安全，能按自己的节奏讲述自己的故事是多么重要。在治疗中，一个人经历的细节可能会随着时间的推移慢慢浮现，有时跨越多次会诊。但要实现这一点，人们实际上需要能够参加他们的会诊。当一个人处于康复的脆弱阶段时，像清晰的预约提醒、简单的沟通和可靠的日程安排这样的小事，在帮助他们保持与治疗的联系方面可以产生真正的不同。Write-up受到超过50,000名临床医生的信赖。如果您想亲自尝试，可以使用描述中的链接获取最多五名用户的免费试用。
And the code Marianne 30. Now, back to the show. So things were going really well. When was the first sign that maybe things were starting to not go quite so well for you? Well, you know, I was... I can only speak about my experience. You know, we've seen the, like the Louis Theroux documentary. and the boy bands and stuff like that.
以及代码Marianne 30。现在，回到节目。所以事情进展得非常顺利。你第一次感觉到事情可能开始不太顺利是什么时候？嗯，你知道，我……我只能谈谈我的经历。你知道，我们看过路易·泰鲁的纪录片，还有那些男子乐队之类的。
Obviously, I did a show years ago called The Big Reunion, which was slightly different documentary style, edited in a certain way. I wasn't in the greatest place, you know, when we were filming that. But I remember the third single went top 10. Thank God, that was I Can Make You Feel Good. Second single went top 10. Sorry, fourth single went top 10.
显然，我几年前参加过一个叫《大重聚》的节目，那是一种稍微不同的纪录片风格，以某种方式剪辑。我们拍摄时，我的状态不是最好的。但我记得第三首单曲进入了前十名。谢天谢地，那是《I Can Make You Feel Good》。第二首单曲进入了前十名。抱歉，第四首单曲进入了前十名。
Then it was like number 16, but I was still getting top of the post. You know. Because you were Kavanaugh, right? Yeah, and I was kept getting magazine covers, you know, like from Smashits were just brilliant. There was an editor that took over called Gav, his passed away now, unfortunately. It's such an amazing, amazing guy. And he just kept putting me on the cover.
然后排名到了第16位，但我还是能上《Top of the Pops》。你知道，因为你是卡瓦纳，对吧？是的，我一直上杂志封面，你知道，比如《Smash Hits》的封面，真是太棒了。当时有一位接手的编辑叫加夫，他现在已经去世了，很遗憾。他是一个非常非常了不起的人。他一直把我放在封面上。
Well, you sold magazines, I guess. And I bought them. Well, thank you. And just to see, you know, like this magazine that I bought every two weeks for years. Powerful start. Yeah. And then there was the Smash It's tours and then winning the awards. words, stuff like that. So that first round with that first album was great. Then I went over to Asia
嗯，我想你卖出了杂志。而我买了它们。嗯，谢谢。只是为了看看，你知道，就像这本我多年来每两周买一次的杂志。强大的开端。是的。然后是《Smash Hits》的巡演，还有赢得奖项之类的。所以第一张专辑的那一轮非常棒。然后我去了亚洲。
and that blew up and that was like nothing I'd ever experienced before because they loved, you know, I guess teen idols from the UK and they loved soul music and my stuff was quite soulful. And anyway, then I left the manager. It just wasn't working out and, you know, I write about it better in the book. And um... But you lost your personal assistant at that time and it sounded like she was a real source of support. Yeah, she was fantastic, Ying. And that was really sad because obviously she was part of his management, you know.
那儿的情况火爆起来，那是我从未经历过的，因为他们喜欢，你知道，我想是来自英国的青少年偶像，他们喜欢灵魂乐，而我的作品很有灵魂感。总之，后来我离开了经纪人。事情进展得不顺利，你知道，我在书里写得更详细。而且……但你当时失去了你的私人助理，听起来她是真正的支持来源。是的，她太棒了，英。那真的很令人难过，因为显然她是经纪公司的一部分，你知道。
But yeah, you just started to... It was the second album, basically. I went to Italy to record it. Um, they pumped a lot more money in it. As they did in those days, you know, had the Spice Girls producers on this one. So we lived there for three months in this beautiful villa. and wrote the album from scratch every day
但是的，你只是开始……基本上是第二张专辑。我去了意大利录制。嗯，他们投入了更多的钱。就像那时候一样，你知道，这次请了辣妹组合的制作人。所以我们在那栋美丽的别墅里住了三个月，每天从零开始写专辑。
had like a chef and an old Italian grandmother would look after us and with driver didn't realize if it was all going on my bill of course because you don't and that's fine it was an amazing experience my family flew out and then the big comeback single
有厨师，还有一位老意大利祖母照顾我们，还有司机。我没意识到这一切都记在我的账上，当然，因为你不会去想，那没关系，那是一次很棒的经历。我的家人飞了过来，然后是那首重磅回归单曲。
for the second album it went in at number 13 which these days would be seen as brilliant and it was like oh, okay, it's not gone top ten. Now I'm getting like cooler press. I'm getting that covers of attitude. I'm getting, you know, the gay press.
第二张专辑的单曲排在第13位，在今天看来会被认为是辉煌的，当时的感觉是：“哦，好吧，没进前十。”现在我开始得到更酷的媒体关注。我上了《Attitude》的封面，你知道，同性恋媒体。
And a little more mature. I'd been to L.A. and worked out with this fitness trainer who becomes my dear friend. And so I'm more adult and growing up and I'm writing my own stuff. But you're also spending loads of money. I'm starting to spend money. I've got advice from accountant that... Maybe it was mismanagement advice.
而且更成熟了一点。我去过洛杉矶，和一位健身教练一起锻炼，他成了我亲爱的朋友。所以我更成熟了，长大了，我在写自己的东西。但你也在花大量的钱。我开始花钱了。我从会计那里得到了建议……也许那是管理不善的建议。
Yeah, you know. And I must never blame anyone. one for my past because that doesn't serve me or anyone else. But I could have made some better decisions or I took better advice, let's say. Hindsight is 2020 vision as they say. Yeah. And then the single after that, I think, went to number 26. It's like, oh my God, they're pumping money into it.
是的，你知道。我绝不能因为我的过去而责怪任何人，因为那对我或任何人都没好处。但我本可以做出更好的决定，或者说，听取更好的建议。俗话说，事后诸葛亮总是看得最清楚。是的。然后在那之后的单曲，我想，排到了第26位。就像是，“哦，天哪，他们投入了那么多钱。”
But they kept shoving me out to Asia, which was doing brilliant. I remember you told this story in the book that you came out of an event. And usually there'd been throngs of girls screaming your name. when you came out and there was nothing. And they asked you when so-and-so was coming out? Yep, yeah. That must have been quite the adjustment as well. Yeah, that was, I mean, you know, some of the bands talk about it,
但他们一直把我推向亚洲，那里的表现非常出色。我记得你在书里讲过这个故事，你从一个活动中出来。通常会有成群结队的女孩尖叫着你的名字，当你出来时，却什么都没有。她们问你某某人什么时候出来？是的，没错。那一定也是一种很大的心理落差。是的，那是，我的意思是，你知道，有些乐队谈论过这件事。
how they would, you know, we'd all go on nights out sometimes and then go straight to GMTV, not GMTV, SMTV. Still half drunk, basically. Yeah, and undersliped. Other things, you know, you don't know. You know, I was hanging out with people that were older than me because I wasn't in a band, so I'd be hanging out with the, cool fashion people or the
他们会，你知道，我们有时会一起出去玩，然后直接去GMTV，不，是SMTV。基本上还半醉着。是的，睡眠不足。还有其他事情，你知道，你不知道。你知道，我和比我大的人混在一起，因为我不在乐队里，所以我经常和酷酷的时尚人士或者……
still very lonely but but banging friends or you know meeting people at this cool place called the Met Bar coming back to my hotel I'm drinking they all go home at three o'clock in the morning and I've got to be up at six for you know all self-imposed and yeah so that I remember coming out of
依然非常孤独，但和朋友们在一起，或者你知道，在那个叫Met Bar的酷地方认识人。回到酒店，我喝着酒，他们凌晨三点都回家了，而我六点就得起床，你知道，这一切都是自找的。是的，所以我记得从……
this was the third sing sorry the third sing off the second album and you know I talk about performing it and nobody really knew it and oh god you And then going outside and there's, did always wait, the fans, you know. Mm-hmm. They were kind of like, oh, cap, cap, go over as I always used to. And when a step's coming out.
这是第二张专辑的第三首单曲，抱歉，第三首单曲，你知道我谈到表演它时，没人真的知道它，哦天哪，你……然后走到外面，那里总是等着粉丝，你知道。嗯。她们有点像，“哦，卡夫，卡夫，过来，”像我以前总是做的那样。然后“Steps”组合出来了。
Right. You know, and I was like, oh, um, oh, right. Oh, okay, well, you go and ask them. I'm like, oh, okay, yeah, yeah, of course. And so you start. A bit crestfallen, though. Hmm. They went waiting for me.
对。你知道，我就像，“哦，嗯，哦，好吧，你去问她们吧。”我就像，“哦，好吧，是的，当然。”所以你开始……有点垂头丧气。嗯。她们不是在等我。
Yeah. They just wanted me to get the inside of knowledge on steps. Yeah. And it's those little things that start to chip away. And then you've got the rest of the day to yourself, because you're in London. There's nothing in the diary that day. So you're back in your hotel room. Of course, I didn't realise I had addiction issues at this point.
是的。她们只是想让我提供关于Steps的内幕消息。是的。就是那些小事开始一点点蚕食你。然后你剩下的一天就自己过了，因为你在伦敦。那天日程表上什么都没有。所以你回到酒店房间。当然，我当时没意识到我有成瘾问题。
So you got the mini bar in the corner. Got the mini bar. You've got, but you've got the gym in the hotel. So you do a bit of that. But then you know, you've earned a drink there, right? You've heard a drink. And then it started to change effect on me the drink. It started to comfort me and give me, just be able to switch off.
所以角落里有迷你吧。有迷你吧。你有……但酒店里有健身房。所以你做一点运动。但你知道，你应得一杯酒，对吧？你应得一杯酒。然后酒开始对我产生影响。它开始安慰我，让我能够关掉……
from this kind of... Because it's kind of an anaesthetic, isn't it? It takes the edge off. Yep. And that's why it can very quickly become problematic if you've got more and more problems rising. Yep, absolutely. In the background, my father had cancer,
因为这是一种麻醉剂，不是吗？它减轻了痛苦。是的。这就是为什么如果你有越来越多的问题，它很快就会变得很有问题。是的，绝对是。在背景中，我父亲得了癌症。
so there was all that going on. And, you know, the funds were going down. But I was still so young. Still spending like a millionaire, though. I was still spending a lot. And, you know, like, but not necessarily, I wasn't buying sports cars and, you know, going to like stripper clubs and, you know, being wild, I was just careless with it, you know.
所以所有这些事情都在发生。而且，你知道，资金在减少。但我还那么年轻。虽然花钱像个百万富翁。我依然花了很多钱。而且，你知道，不一定，我没有买跑车，也没有去脱衣舞俱乐部，也没有疯狂挥霍，我只是对钱很粗心，你知道。
But then, you know, if you think it's going to last forever, then you do make different decisions, don't you at that time? Yeah. And like I say, I take full responsibility. It's brought me to where I am, you know, I'm glad to have had these experiences. And that's when it started to change slightly. And but look at it. I'd made enough money to, I felt quite shameful that my career was over at 21. That's how I perceived it. Right. And that's when I moved to LA, like you do.
但后来，你知道，如果你认为它会永远持续下去，那么你当时确实会做出不同的决定，不是吗？是的。就像我说的，我承担全部责任。它把我带到了今天的位置，你知道，我很高兴有这些经历。那就是事情开始稍微改变的时候。但看看吧，我赚了足够的钱，我感到很羞愧，因为我的职业生涯在21岁就结束了。我是这么认为的。对。那就是我搬到洛杉矶的时候，就像你做的那样。
You know, I move like you do. I mean, I'm saying that. So try and break America. Well, yeah, I mean, I say like you do because it was so random and it was so, it was quite delusional. But yeah, I'd saw all this success in Asia. And it was all me, it was me and a lot of American artists in the charts.
你知道，我搬过去，就像你做的那样。我的意思是，我这么说是因为这太随机了，而且太……相当自欺欺人。但是的，我看到了在亚洲取得的所有成功。那全是我，是我和许多美国艺人在排行榜上。
And I just kept thinking, you know what? I'd already met this person, this fitness trainer who became my best pal. And so I went out there. Yeah. And that was a whole different, well, that's a whole few chapters in there, the Hollywood. The Hollywood years. The Hollywood years, which isn't as glamorous as it sounds as we know. But there was some life-changing beautiful moments, but also there was some darkness there
我一直在想，你知道吗？我已经认识了这个人，这位健身教练成了我最好的朋友。所以我去了那里。是的。那完全是另一回事，好吧，那是书里的好几个章节，好莱坞。好莱坞岁月。好莱坞岁月，正如我们所知，并不像听起来那么光鲜亮丽。但也有一些改变人生的美好时刻，但也存在一些黑暗面。
because I was free. I was 21 years old. nobody knew of anything of my past only the good stuff I showed them you get the O-1 visa you pay for it with a lawyer so the O-1 says he's had all this success you show the magazine covers you show the huge hits of the awards the SMASCHs awards
因为我自由了。我当时21岁。没人知道我的过去，只知道我展示给他们的好的一面。你拿到O-1签证，你花钱请律师办理，所以O-1签证上写着他取得了所有这些成就，你展示杂志封面，展示那些巨大的热门奖项，SMASCHs奖。
I don't know what Smashes Awards is it could be a you know a Brit to them from the trophy shop down the road or it could be something really esteemable I mean I guess it was in the pop world and that's when I moved out there Yeah, 21.
我不知道什么是Smashes奖，它可能只是街角奖杯店里的一个英式奖杯，也可能是一些真正值得尊敬的东西。我的意思是，我猜它是在流行音乐界，那就是我搬到那里的时候。是的，21岁。
When was the red jogging bottoms era? Was that back in the UK? That was towards the end. Right. I've just seen them in my drop. Have you still got them? Oh, wow. The Adidas.
红色慢跑裤时代是什么时候？那是回到英国的时候吗？那是快结束的时候。对。我刚在我的草稿里看到它们。你还留着它们吗？哦，哇。阿迪达斯。
If people aren't sure about that, tell us what I mean by the red jogging bottoms. Well, there's three, well, I'd say there's, I actually wrote this and this sounds quite garny. I wrote it in three acts, act one, act two and act three. Act one is the pop years. Act two is me going to Hollywood trying to make it, not making it, coming back with my, you know, tail between my legs, no money, a tan and a transatlantic, weird transatlantic accent. So you looked hot. I looked good because I was still getting away with it, but there was this slow burning addiction that got hold of me, right?
如果人们不确定那是什么，告诉我们我所说的红色慢跑裤是什么意思。嗯，有三，嗯，我会说有，我实际上写了这个，听起来有点自恋。我把它写成了三幕，第一幕，第二幕和第三幕。第一幕是流行音乐岁月。第二幕是我去好莱坞试图成功，结果没成功，灰溜溜地回来，没钱，晒黑了，还有一种奇怪的跨大西洋口音。所以你看上去很火辣。我看起来不错，因为我还能应付得过去，但有一种缓慢燃烧的瘾症控制了我，对吧？
And then at three. We were aware of that at that stage, do you think? I knew, yeah. I mean, I knew there was something about, I was in so. much denial, Marianne. I think you know that we weren't as informed as we are now
然后是第三幕。你认为我们在那个阶段意识到了吗？我知道，是的。我的意思是，我知道有些不对劲，我处于极度的否认中，玛丽安。我想你知道我们当时不像现在这样了解成瘾，尤其是心理健康，因为我认为成瘾是一个心理健康问题。毫无疑问。我的意思是，我有很多自尊心和羞耻感，我仍然非常有野心，它还没有恶化到红色慢跑裤的地步。
about addiction, especially mental health because I think addiction is a mental health issue. There's no doubt about that. I mean and I had a lot of pride and shame and I was still very ambitious and it hadn't turned on me to the point where the red jogging bottoms
那是书的第三幕部分，叫“游戏结束”，我想有一章叫“游戏结束”，我正处于人生的最低谷。所以那是最后的低谷之一，我陷入了全面的成瘾，危险的，非常危险的成瘾。你知道，也涉及毒品。
and that's say in the Act 3 part of the book where Game Over I think there's a chapter called Game Over where I'm just at rock bottom. And so that's one of the final rock bottoms where I was in full addiction, dangerous, very dangerous addiction. You know, drugs were involved as well.
而且，你知道，在康复室里，你会听到人们的故事，他们穿着同样的衣服，你知道，洗澡。我的一位康复中的朋友常说，我知道你什么时候有麻烦，或者什么时候复发，或者什么时候处于黑暗中，你没有好转，因为你穿着那条红色慢跑裤，真的，我已经一两周没洗或换衣服了。
And, you know, in the rooms of recovery, you hear people's stories where they wear the same clothes for, you know, shower. And a friend of mine who was in recovery used to say, I knew when you was in trouble or when you was relapsing or when you was in the dark, you weren't getting better because you'd have the red jogging bottoms on really i hadn't washed or changed for a week or two
你知道，那是快结束的时候。是的，那时有人在照顾你吗？还是说你对他们的声音充耳不闻，即使他们是……人们尝试过，但正如我们所知，成瘾一旦你孤立自己，嗯，你要做什么，你知道，你需要你的毒品，你需要你的，对我来说是酒精，它始于酒精，也终于酒精。如果没有酒精，我永远不会碰毒品。酒精对我产生的影响与普通饮酒者非常不同，这是我最终……
you know that's that was towards the end yeah and was anyone looking out for you at that time or were you kind of deaf to their to their voices either even if they were um people tried but as we know it's um addiction once you isolated on your own um and uh what are you going to do do, you know, you need your fix, you need your, for me it was alcohol and it started with alcohol and it finished with alcohol. I would never have touched drugs without alcohol. Alcohol did for me something very different than it does the normal drinker, which is something that I've finally,
但不是最终，而是我进入康复中心并有了一段时间后才理解的事情。关于它是一种过敏之类的说法，还有渴望的现象，诸如此类。对我来说，它以某种方式点亮了我的大脑。它没有，它给了我能量。所以它给了我自信，给了我能量。它并没有真正让我平静下来。但我也曾有过一次。
but not finally, but something that I understood once I got into recovery and got a bit of time behind me. There's a whole thing about it being an allergy and stuff like that and the phenomenon of craving, stuff like that. For me, it just, it lit up my brain in a way. It didn't, it gave me energy. So it gave me confidence, it gave me energy. It didn't really calm me down. But also, I had this once.
所以它真的点亮了你？它点亮了我。而那种渴望，我无法理解的是，我可能过得很好，对吧？喝酒的念头根本不会进入我的脑海，我可能刚又戒酒了，生活又开始好转了，这就是我不断复发的原因。
So it lit you up, really? It lit me up. And the craving, what I couldn't get my head round is, I could be having a really good day, right? and the thought of a drink would not enter my head and I might have just got sober again and life is starting to get good again this is why I kept relapsing
这对任何可能理解、可能与此产生共鸣的听众来说很重要，毫无征兆地，我会产生一个盲点，说现在喝一杯吧。我知道过去发生过什么，就像你脑子里有个小声音。是的，好吧，是的，我想你想这么叫它。
and it's important for anyone listening to who might understand might relate to this and out of nowhere I would get this blind spot that would say have a drink now I know what's happened in the past as like a little voice in your head yeah well yeah I guess you want to call it that
尽管有过去因为我喝酒而发生的所有证据，但那都被抛诸脑后了。就像我处于恍惚状态，或者我曾经处于恍惚状态。所以那不是对酒的渴望。那只是一个盲点。它只会说喝一杯吧。
against all evidence that's happened in the past because of my drinking that goes out the window. It's like I'm in a trance, or I was in a trance. And so it wasn't a craving for a drink. It was just a blinds. It would just go have a drink.
我毫无防备。所以我拿起第一杯酒，心想我只喝一杯。那就是渴望开始的时候。对。一旦它进入我的系统。一杯永远不够，对吧？一旦它进入系统，确实如此。
And I had no defence. So I'd pick up the first drink, thinking I'll just have one. And that's when the craving began. Right. Once it goes in my system. One's never enough, right? Once it goes in the system, exactly.
渴望开始了。然后有些日子可能只是……就像你点燃了导火索，正如他们所说。是的。而且，你知道，有些日子可能只是一瓶酒。有些日子可能最终变成三天的狂饮，我根本停不下来。但你可以肯定，它总是会以某种，你知道，某种插曲结束，是的，一些不好的事情。是的。在这一旅程中，你在书中说你当时在《Loose Women》节目上。
The craving began. And then it's some days it might just be... Like you've lit the blue touch paper, as they say. Yeah. And, you know, some days it would just be. a bottle. Some days it might end up being a three day, a bend up where I just can't stop. But you can be sure it would always end in some kind of, you know, episode of some, yeah, something not good. Yeah. And sort of during this journey, you say in the book that you're on
是的。我必须承认，我在那个阶段放下了书，去谷歌搜索了一下。是的。我的意思是，我想有些人说过要说出来。那确实很难看。我刚从美国回来。我记得走进一个，我写了所有这些新歌，和一些伟大的作家合作，声音非常不同。我真的为它们感到骄傲，你知道。
loose women. Yes. And I have to confess that I did put the book down at that stage and I googled that. Yeah. I mean, I think some people have said to say that. That's a hard watch actually. I was, I'd come back from America. And I remember going into a, I'd had all these new songs that I'd written with some great writers, very different sound. And I was really proud of them, you know,
因为我在那里确实做了一些好事。是的。并非全是，你知道，混乱。我去参加了一些唱片公司的会议，把它们放出来，你知道。感觉真的很振奋。是的，我的意思是，你知道。有很多动力。是的。
because I did do some good stuff out there. Yeah. It wasn't all, you know, chaos. And I went for some label meetings and said them back and, you know. It felt really energizing. Yeah, I mean, you know. There's a lot of drive going on. Yeah.
我当时想，你知道，我回来了，而且，你知道，我很乐意，他们说，嗯，你需要参加一个真人秀节目。对。我已经离开10年了。你知道，你不能去，当我21岁第一次事业结束后离开时，你可以，没有丛林可以去。没有《老大哥》的房子。没有。也没有Instagram来维持你的存在感。不，你可以。
I was like, you know, I'm back and, you know, I'd love to, and they said, well, you kind of need to do a reality TV show. Right. I've been away for 10 years. You know, you couldn't go in the, when I was 21 and left after the career finished the first time, you could, there was no jungle to go in. There was no big brother house. There was no. There was no, Instagram either to maintain your presence. No, you could.
所以我说，哦，好吧。而且我当时，我快没钱了。我甚至付不起父母的抵押贷款。对。我该怎么办？所以我找到了这个，我问人们，只有关于问经纪人的真人秀，嗯，有一个叫《Grease Is the Word》。那是什么？
And so I said, oh, right. And I was, I was kind of running out of money fast. I couldn't even pay my parents' mortgage. Right. What do I do? So I found this, I was asking people, there's only reality shows about asking agents, well, there's this one called Greece is the word. What's that?
你看上去有点像丹尼·祖科，对吧？当时有人这么说。也许现在更像约翰·特拉沃尔塔。但那没什么错。我们爱约翰。所以我当时想，哦，好吧，好的，我会参加。所以我排队参加了这个选秀节目。接下来你知道的，我每周都和这些戏剧孩子一起参加。
And you look a bit Danny Zuccoe, right? Somebody said that at the time. Maybe more like John DeVolter now these days. But nothing wrong with that. We love John. So I was like, oh right, okay, I'll do that. So I lined up for this talent show. And the next thing you know, I'm on it every week with all these theatre kids.
我每周都在全国电视上试镜丹尼·祖科的角色，我每周都被选中。长话短说，我没赢。另一个赢了的家伙更值得，他来自舞台学校，19岁。我当时32岁，试图让我的事业起步。但公众确实一直投票给我，我对此非常感激。你再次俘获了他们的心。是的。我又可以做我热爱的事情唱歌了，你知道。这有点像《X音素》风格的节目，因为我们每周都唱歌。而我的成瘾。
And I'm auditioning for the part of Danny Zucco. national television every week and I kept getting put through every week. Long story short, I didn't win. The other guy won who deserved it much more. He's from stage school who was 19 years old. I was like 32 trying to get my career going. But the public did keep voting me and I was very grateful for that. You captured their hearts again. Yeah. And I got to sing on doing what I love again, you know. It was kind of like an X Factor style show really because we just sang every week. And my addiction.
她在背景中。对。你知道，我还在喝酒，而且，你知道，即使在那些节目中，那些现场直播的节目中，我上台前也得在厕所喝几杯。没人知道。嗯。我被安排上《Loose Women》谈论在那之后即将发行的一张唱片。
she was in the background. Right. You know, I was still drinking and, you know, even on some of those, some of those shows, you know, some of those live shows, I'd have to have a couple of drinks in the toilet before I went on. Nobody knew. Mm-hmm. And I got put on loose women to talk about a record that was coming out off the back of that
我以前的唱片公司发行了精选集之类的东西。前一天晚上我出去了。正如我们所做的那样，我想我们称之为自我破坏。只出去喝一杯。对。好吧，这一杯变成了100杯，还有其他东西。我只是在这些陌生人的房子里醒来，其实非常非常友好。
and that my old label put out like a greatest hits or whatever you may call it. And I went out the night before. As we do, I think we call it self-sabotage. Just go out for one. Right. Well, this one turned into 100 and the rest, other stuff. And I just woke up in these couple of strangers' house through a very, very nice, actually.
他们说，哦，你还好吗？我让车去接我参加IDV。我简直在地狱里，就像最严重的宿醉。在那一刻，我发现了“以毒攻毒”，那是我饮酒习惯的真正改变，一旦“以毒攻毒”被引入。
And they said, oh, you're okay. I'd got the car to pit me up there for IDV. And I just was in hell, like the worst hangover. At that point, I discovered hair of the dog. and that was when that was the real change in my drinking once the hair of the dog
哦，天哪，我可以逃脱，好吧，我以为我找到了这个疗法，天哪，我可以正常工作，再也不用宿醉了。
was introduced oh boy I could get away well I thought I got this cure oh my god I can function never have to have a hangover again
你知道这太神奇了，直到它不再神奇。是的，我记得我不仅仅是宿醉，需要几片扑热息痛，我当时……
you know this is amazing until it wasn't yeah and I remember just I wasn't just hung over where you need a couple of paracetamol I was like
我病得很重，我有震颤谵妄，我以前从未有过，我现在明白这是你的神经系统崩溃了，你的身体因为我的系统方式而渴望更多，我记得你的身体依赖了，我是酒鬼，你知道。
I was very unwell I had the DTs which I'd never had before which I now understand is your nervous system is shot your body's craving more because of the way my system is and I remember your body was dependent I was alcoholic you know
我记得开车去那里时心想，我怎么能做这个现场采访，我简直在发抖，我停下来，我对司机说，你需要停下来，我记得跑进一家商店还是什么，我说书里写了，我唯一有的就是快点，你知道什么不会有伏特加的味道，当然它闻起来就是我，酒鬼。
and I remember the driving there thinking how can I do this live interview like I'm literally shaking and I stopped off I said to the driver you need to stop I remember running into an S or whatever I said it was in the book and the only thing that I had something quick you know what's not going to smell vodka of course it smells me just alcoholic
假装它没有。出于恐惧，我一口气喝光了。接下来你知道的，我在现场直播电视上。而且，是的，它，它，它本可能严重十倍。它本可能更糟，但我侥幸过关了。但是的，它不是，它不是。我认为是小组中女士们巧妙的采访风格真正帮助推动了它。
pretend that it doesn't. And I just out of fear, glugged the whole thing. And next thing, you know, I'm on live television. And, yeah, it was, it was, it could have been ten times. It could have been a lot worse, but by the skin of my teeth, I got through it. But yeah, it wasn't, it wasn't. I think it was the artful interviewing style of the ladies on the panel that really helped move that along.
好吧，感谢上帝，是的。我的意思是，我在那个演播室里是个定时炸弹。我的意思是，他们，显然当时，我的经纪人第二天给我打了电话。关于它。我的意思是，他们最终在帕丁顿的某个床位房里醒来，心想他们怎么最终回到这里。就像，昨天发生了什么？我不记得了。我开始出现断片。对。我以为断片。
Well, thank God, yeah. I mean, I was a loose cannon in that studio. I mean, they, apparently at the time, my agent called me the next day. about it. I mean, they ended up in some bed sitting Paddington and woke up up thinking how they ended up back here. Like, what happened yesterday? I didn't remember. I started getting blackouts. Right. I thought blackouts
意味着你倒在地上昏迷了。而不是你还能正常工作。但没有记忆。而且没有记忆。就像你的记忆关闭了。是的。而我的恰好是在全国电视上。你知道。他说，你知道，你被禁止……你再也不能上节目了。所以我被禁了。我的意思是，几年后当我第一次去康复中心时，他们解除了禁令。
meant you fell to the floor and blacked out. Not that you functioned. But had no memory of it. And had no memory. Like your memory shut down. Yeah. And mine just happened to be on national television. You know. And he said, you know, you banned from a... You can never go on a show again. So I got a band. I mean, they lifted it a few years later when I went to my first rehab,
他们说，哦，你会来谈谈吗？好的。但我没什么可谈的，你知道。对。我不想只是去。所以我昨天在你的Instagram上看到你现在已经戒酒四年了？四年，清醒戒酒，是的。
they said, oh, will you come on and talk about it? Okay. But I had nothing to talk about, you know. Right. I didn't want to just go on. So I think I saw on your Instagram yesterday that you're now four years clean? Four years, sober clean, yeah.
过去几年过得快得疯狂。我曾经是那种连四个小时、四分钟都坚持不了的人，你知道。所以你们所有人。这是一个真正的庆祝，有很多值得骄傲的地方。是的，谢谢。这不仅仅是放下那种药物来源，因为对我来说，那是快结束的时候。
Which has gone by crazy fast the last couple of years. And I was one of those guys that couldn't get four hours, four minutes sometimes, you know. So you all. It's a real celebration, lots to be proud of. Yeah, and thank you. And it's not just about putting that down the source of medicine, because for me it was towards the end.
实际上是关于没有它如何生活。我们采取了什么工具来度过难关？所以我真的很感激，你知道，就像过去，我的意思是，只是对，能够写一本书。我知道我绝没有醉酒。它简直就是自然而然地来到我身边。只是你，对吧？只是我。
It's about living without it actually. And what tools do we put in place to get by? And so I'm just really grateful that, you know, like the last, I mean, just right, being able to write a book. I know that I was in no way intoxicated. It just literally came to me. It's just you, right? It's just me.
我并没有试图给人留下深刻印象。我不知道谁会读它。你知道，我只是，我真的很享受。人们说，哦，写书难吗？其实并不难。有几个时刻我写到了我去世的姐姐。但我当时从未处理过任何这些事情。深埋起来，对吧？
And I wasn't trying to impress. I didn't know who would read it. You know, I just, I really enjoyed. People say, oh, is it hard to write? It actually wasn't. There was moments where I wrote about my sister who passed away. But I never dealt with any of that stuff at the time. Buried it deep, right?
我深埋起来，你知道，我借酒消愁。喝酒的好借口。我姐姐死了。我父亲死了。你知道，我妈妈得了阿尔茨海默病。但我现在几乎通过写作处理了它。所以这其实是一次很棒的经历。对我来说，最重要的一部分是我从读者那里得到的反馈，他们以为它可能是某种东西，但我看到它其实是另一种东西。
I buried it deep, you know, and I was drinking on it. And great excuse to drink. My sister's died. My father's died. You know, my mum's got Alzheimer's. But I almost have processed it now through writing. So it's been a great experience, actually. And the most important part about it to me is the feedback that I get from readers who thought it might be one thing, but I've seen that it's something else.
你可以看到它是如何，它是如何。然后像现在这样，它是如何进行的，以及实际上这是可能的。是的。即使对于一个每天、每小时都要喝酒的人来说。是的。绝对。你知道。而且我绝不是康复方面的权威。我的康复并不完美。好的。我没有碰任何毒品或。
You can see that it's been, how it's been. And then like now how it's going and how actually that's possible. Yeah. Even for someone that is having to drink every day, every hour. Yeah. Absolutely. You know. And I am in no way. an oracle about recoverer. My recovery is not perfect. Okay. I haven't touched any drugs or
喝酒，但我仍然会犯错。你们都会。这是关于找到你的适应性应对策略。绝对。但我知道，就像今天早上，你知道，我们交换了几条短信。我直到要离开时才真正看它们，因为我每天早上必须做某些事情来保持健康。让我的头脑保持在正确的位置。所以对我来说，我向一个我不理解的上帝祈祷，或者不是一个神圣的上帝。我请求，你知道，让我今天有用。让我，你知道，引导我，如果你愿意，你知道，好的，奇怪的方向，上帝，如果那是你想叫它的名字。因为我的思维和意志力让我一事无成。
drink, but I still make mistakes. You all do. It's the thing about finding your adaptive coping strategies. Absolutely. But I know, like this morning, you know, about we swapped a couple of texts. I hadn't actually looked at them until I was about to leave because I have to do certain things every morning to keep you well. To keep my head in the right place. So for me, I pray to a God that I don't understand or that isn't a holy God. I ask for, you know, let me be useful today. Let me, you know, guide me if you want, you know, good, oddly direction, God, if that's what you want to call it. Because my thinking and my willpower got me nowhere.
它让我陷入了一些糟糕的地方。你是在起草另一个。是的，我只是说你今天开车。就像，我的驾驶技术不太好，正如我们所知。所以你能开车吗？我和所谓的更高力量有一种很酷的关系，如果你愿意的话。这也许也关于责任感。是的，是的，绝对。
It got me into some bad places. You're kind of drafting in another. Yeah, I just say you drive today. Like, my driving is not very good as we know. so can you drive and I have a really cool relationship with call it a higher power if you want It's about like accountability maybe as well Yeah yeah absolutely
但这并不总是容易的，所以我喝酒，我现在已经大约18个月没喝酒了。哇，好的。我从来没有真正的问题。是的，只是我想我不认为我需要这个。我今天制作了Stu，我们去参加了一个活动。是去年晚些时候吗？其他人不一定喜欢你不喝酒。他们喜欢人们带。
But it's not always easy so I don't drink I haven't drunk now for about 18 months Wow okay I'd never really problematic Yeah just I thought I don't think I need this And I produced today Stu and I went to an event Was it late last year? Other people don't necessarily like you're not drinking Do they like people are bringing
在活动中用托盘端着饮料，并试图给我加满，你知道，桃红葡萄酒或起泡酒之类的。就像，我不喝酒。我有一些，我试图问，我可以喝点无酒精的吗？几乎在回避我，就像，哦，我不知道。你得去酒吧。是的。
Bringing drinks around on trays at events And trying to talk top me up with, you know, rosé or seco or whatever. And it's like, I don't drink. And I have something, I was trying to ask, can I have something non-alcoholic? And almost shunning me and like, oh, I don't know. You'll have to go to the bar. Yeah.
就是那个。接骨木花，有氧运动，或者之类的。我不会介意的。是的。是的。他们很乐意走来走去给你加满。保持清醒并不容易。我们今天在这里买了一些康普茶。
And it's that. With the elder flower, cardio, or sort of. I wouldn't have minded that. Yeah. Yeah. They were happy to walk around just topping you up. It isn't easy to be sober. We bought some kombucha here today.
是的。我其实很喜欢康普茶。是的。做一个不喝酒的人并不总是容易的。特别是如果你周围的人一直是有问题的饮酒者，或者他们是，他们会想让你和他们一起喝，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，我真正戒酒后失去了很多朋友。
Yeah. I love kombucha, actually. Yeah. It's not easy always to be the person that's not drinking. And especially if people around you have been problematic drinkers or are, they will want you to drink with them, won't they? Yeah. I mean, I lost a lot of friends once I properly got sober.
但我也会说，这与他们或我无关。事情就是这样。你不再被邀请参加活动。这可能很公平，因为在我喝酒的某些时候，那可能是一场噩梦。但我记得我真正清醒的第一年，联系到你所说的玛丽安，我那第一年，我想我已经。
But I also will say, and that's nothing to do with them or me. It's just the way things are. You stop getting invited to things. And that's probably fair enough, because it was probably a nightmare towards some points in my drinking. but I remember that first year in relating to what you said Marion that first year of my proper sobriety where I thought I've got
你知道，康复是我故事的一部分，我去过两次，但最后一次我去的时候，我在进去之前差点死了，我出来后，我就想这就是了，我必须认真对待它。所以我去了，我开始参加会议，你知道，有各种各样的会议，他们称之为12步康复。
you know rehab's a part of my story I've been twice but the last one I went to where I nearly died before I went in I came out and I was like this is it like I've got to take this seriously now so I went I started going to meetings you know there's all different types of meetings they call it 12 step recovery
你知道，外面有会议，AA，NA，随便你怎么叫它。所以我也会那样做，但我会，我哪儿也没去。我哪儿也没去。我其实像个隐士一样生活。不是以一种令人沮丧的方式，但我，我会受邀参加一些活动，甚至家庭活动，我必须设定界限，说，你知道吗？你在那个阶段不能信任自己。是的，我只是有一段时间不能待在那种环境里。也许不是因为我要喝酒，而是因为我感到多么不舒服。我所有的受体都在说，哦，是的，这让我想起了那个。即使我现在回到曼彻斯特，
you know there's meetings out there A-A-A-N-A whatever you want to call it So I would do that, but I would, I didn't go anywhere. I didn't go anywhere. I lived like a hermit actually. Not in a depressing way, but I, I would get invited to things or even family events and I'd have to put boundaries and say, do you know what? You can't trust yourself at that stage. Yeah, and I just can't be around it for a while. Maybe not because I was going to drink, but because how uncomfortable I felt. All my receptors were going, oh yeah, this reminds me of that. are even when I go back to Manchester at this point,
我会去看我妈妈，我会经过所有的酒吧。我过去有时在快结束时，当我抑郁时，会独自坐在那里。即使在伦敦，它们也无处不在。熟悉的陌生人，但也是诱因。是的，是的。所以我真的必须，你知道，我对人们说，重塑你自己。是的，是的。
I'd go and see my mum and I'd pass all the pubs. I used to sometimes sitting on my own towards the end when I was depressed. Even in London, they're everywhere. Familiar strangers but also triggers. Yeah, yeah. So I really just had to, you know, and I say to people, reinvent yourself. Yeah, yeah.
安东尼不喝酒时是谁？绝对。他去哪里？他的兴趣是什么？是的。什么能激活你？你期待什么？你喜欢什么？
Who is Anthony when he doesn't drink? Absolutely. Where does he go? What are his interest? Yeah. What does activate you? What do you look forward to? What do you like?
是的，是的。我不知道，因为一切都被压制了。因为你总是和酒精一起做这件事。所以，是的。我的意思是，过去几年，我有时甚至连电话都拿不起来，除非喝一杯。对。我不能。我的意思是，是的，涉及很多创伤。
Yeah, yeah. And I had no idea because it was all squashing. Because you'd always done it with alcohol as well. So, yeah. I mean, the last few years, I couldn't even sometimes pick up the phone without having a drink. Right. I couldn't. I mean, yes, there was a lot of trauma involved.
有死亡。我家里发生了很多事情。这也是你需要支持的信号，虽然。是的，但我认为当你找到一种如此快速的酒精支持版本时，它就在拐角处。它每次都有效，对吧？哦，天哪。它承诺了我很多，有一段时间，你知道，它确实做到了。它立刻安抚了我。
There was deaths. There was all stuff going on in my family. There's a sign you needed support as well, though. Yeah, but I think when you find such a quick version of support in alcohol, which was around the corner. It worked every time, right? Oh, my God. It promised me so much for a while, you know, and it did. It soothed me instantly.
但它最终也夺走了一切。是的。但是，是的，缓慢而稳定，有人告诉我。缓慢而稳定，只是为了今天，就像，我今天不喝酒。好的。有时我坚持得很难，但我只是想我不能。但我会去参加会议，你看。我在伦敦寻找。
But it also eventually took everything away. Yeah. But, yeah, slow and steady, I was told. Slow and steady, and just for today, like, I'm just not going to have a drink today. Okay. Sometimes I'd be holding on by the skin, but I just thought I just can't. But I would go to meetings, you see. And I'm looking in London.
那个社区。是的，顺便说一句，就像，我一直以为AA会议会是人们坐在一起，呻吟，抱怨，你知道，随便什么。我从未去过一个有这么多笑声的地方。人们其实不太谈论喝酒。他们谈论他们的一般生活。我的意思是，前几天会议上有一位女士在谈论洗衣机坏了。但你投入到了那个故事里，对吧？
Of that community. Yeah, and by the way, like, I always thought AA meetings would be people sat around, moaning, complaining, you know, whatever. I've never been in a place where there's so much laughter. People don't really talk so much about the drinking. They talk about their life in general. I mean, there was a lady in a meeting the other day talking about a washing machine breaking down. But you were invested in that story, right?
因为你是某件事的一部分。我认为这就是AA康复小组的事情，因为喝酒可能非常社交，我们也可以非常反社会，不是吗？但你们经常聚在一起。所以当你走出另一边时，复制或创造一个你觉得属于其中的不同社区，真的可以是解决方案的一部分。
Because you're part of something. I think that's the thing with A.A.M. Recovery groups is that because drinking can be very social, we can also be very antisocial, can it? But you come together quite often. So then when you're coming out the other side, replicating or creating a different community that you feel part of can be really part of the solution.
绝对。而且，你知道，我们获得访问权限，你获得12步的访问权限，这听起来非常邪教，非常，但它不是。这只是一个非常简单的生活设计。理解它的唯一方法是通过尝试，通过去，我想。而且我在这方面并不完美。它只是，你知道，你有点，每一个都是有原因的，从1到12。当你到达12时，那更多是关于。你的精神层面，所以服务，帮助他人。我知道外面的东西会修复我。我现在意识到了。听着，获得第一名流行畅销书很棒，这来了，你知道，难以置信。获得，哦，天哪，我大脑里的多巴胺被淹没了。多年来什么都没有，突然人们给了我好评。好吧，我很喜欢。
Absolutely. And, you know, we get access, you get access to the 12 steps, which sounds very cultish and very, but it's not. It's just a very simple design for living. And the only way to understand it is by trying, it is by going, I suppose. And I'm not perfect at it. It's just kind of, you know, you kind of, each one's in order for a reason from 1 to 12. And by the time you get to 12, that's more about. Your spiritual side, so serving, helping others. I know outside stuff is going to fix me. I realise that now. Listen, it was great to get number one pop bestsello and this came, you know, unbelievable. Great to get, oh my God, the dopamine in my brain was flooded. After nothing for years and suddenly people are giving me good reviews. Well, I loved it.
非常感谢。但是，你知道，我必须小心那些东西，因为我不会变得自大，但我会想念它当它消失的时候。但我喜欢的不是卡瓦纳。是安东尼。是的。谢谢。但那是，那是，
Thank you so much. But, you know, I have to be careful of that stuff because I won't get cocky, but I'll miss it when it goes. But it's not Kavanaugh that I liked. It's Anthony. Yes. Thank you. But that is, that is,
安东尼写了这个。是的，你知道。但安东尼过去也写他的歌。是的。我养了一只狗来写我自己。但这才是真实版本的我，你知道，
Anthony wrote this. Yeah, you know. But Anthony used to write his songs as well. Yeah. I got a dog to write myself. But this is the true version of me, you know,
但我必须经历所有这些才能写出来，你知道，它花了这么长时间才奏效是有原因的。门一直关着。我们不感兴趣。然后突然当时间合适时，他们就，你知道，是的。所以告诉我们现在的你。
but I had to go through all that to be able to write it, you know, and there's a reason it took so long for it to work. Doors kept closing it. We're not interested. And then suddenly when the time was right, they were, you know, yeah. So tell us about you now.
你接下来有什么？你的生活中现在有什么？对。好吧，只是为了今天，我在这里和你以及Stu做这个可爱的播客。我只是试图享受它。你知道，我真的在尝试，我必须把我的康复放在第一位，因为如果我不这样做，那么在我意识到之前，我的头脑就乱了。我的意思是收音机，这是一个坏收音机。它告诉我一些不真实的事情。你知道，它很多时候基于恐惧。你知道，我和我的家人，我剩下的家人，主要是我的阿姨和我的，你知道，
What have you got coming up? What's, what's in your life now? Right. Well, just for today, I'm here doing this lovely podcast with you in Stu. And I'm just trying to enjoy it. You know, I'm really trying to, I have to put my recovery first because if I don't, then before I know it, just my head goes. And what I mean by that is radio, it's a bad radio. It tells me things that aren't true. You know, it's based in fear a lot of the time. You know, I have a great relationship with my family, what's left of my family, mainly my aunties and my, you know,
我妈妈和我的表亲们之类的，关系很好。显然我妈妈得了阿尔茨海默病。她89岁了。她在疗养院。她在书里出现了很多。她是。是的。我想写那个。事实上，书是以我和她结束的，不是吗，在疗养院的那一幕？而且，你知道，我能够出席。我不总是舒服地出席，但我能够出席。而且我知道我现在明白感觉不会杀了我。我知道我有，任何听众都从他们担心过的每一件事中幸存下来，100%。我去参加会议，我的创造力回来了。我要回亚洲了，这很疯狂，因为我已经25年没去过那里了。有趣的是，作为卡瓦纳，如果你愿意的话，因为我长期以来一直为那个版本的我感到羞耻。
my mom and my cousins and stuff. Obviously my mum is Alzheimer's. She's 89. She's in a care home. And she's featured a lot in the book. She is. Yeah. And I wanted to write that. In fact, the book finishes with me and her, doesn't it, the scene in the care home? And, you know, I get to be present. I'm not always comfortably present, but I get to be present. And I know I understand now that feelings are not going to kill me. I know that I have, and anyone listening has survived 100% of everything they've ever worried about. And I go to meetings, my creativity is back. I'm going back out to Asia, which is crazy because I've not been there for 25 years. Interestingly, as Kavanaugh, if you like, because I was so ashamed of that version of me for so long.
我现在意识到我仍然可以是那个，只是以不同的方式，因为人们，有些人确实还在听我唱歌，喜欢那个版本。所以我有点在看它。我仍然喜欢那首歌。我仍然有一个英雄。我仍然在跳舞和唱歌。谢谢。
that I'm now realised that I can still be that just in a different way because people, some people do still listen to me and like that version. So I'm kind of seeing it. I still love that song. I still have a hero. I'm still dancing and singing. Thank you.
它就像一个劲量电池。我会说，你和Bop。对。我很高兴。我对那两个很满意。我记得那是他出道时的同一时间。是的。而且，是的，我的意思是，我尽量不谈论。
It's like an energizer. It's you and bop, I would say. Right. I'm happy. I'm happy with those two. I remember that at the same time he came out. Yeah. And yeah, I mean, I try not to talk about.
我正在做的太多事情，因为我过去那样做过，然后我会有点，它不会像我想象的那样奏效。是的，我只是有点，你就在你所在的地方，我就是，但我，但我，我的野心回来了，但以一种健康的方式，我讨厌这么说，但这是我能描述它的唯一方式，我觉得作为一个人，作为一个艺术家，嗯，作为一个作家，作为一个作者，我又被认可了。我的意思是，你知道，他们说一旦你，一旦你戒酒或康复，或者随便你怎么叫它，嗯，你会得到一个你从未想象过的生活，这并不一定意味着你梦想的生活，但我无法想象清醒，我也无法想象成为一名作家，这就是我现在的处境。
too many things that I've got that I'm working on because I did that in the past and then I would kind of it wouldn't work the way I thought it was going to yeah I just kind of take you are where you are day I am and I but but I am I my ambition is back but in a healthy way and I I hate to say this but it's the only way I can describe it I feel somewhat validated again as as a as a human as a as an artist um as a as a as a writer as an author i mean you know they say when once you uh once you get sober or recovery or whatever you want to call it um you'll you'll get a life that you never imagined and that doesn't necessarily mean the life that you dreamed of but i could never imagine a being sober and i could never imagine being an author and that's kind of where i'm at
今天，但是的，我绝对想做更多，还有更多东西，书的可能改编，太棒了，是的，所以我很高兴，而且我，你知道，我从未想象过卡瓦纳·安东尼会如此可爱，当我给他发信息时，他会回复，绝对，我们会进行一次这么棒的采访，谢谢，是的，还有书的评论，在这里，是的，所以谢谢你的可爱，嗯，我祝你接下来的一切顺利。所以目前我们录制时，精装书已经出版了，但平装书夏天会出来，是这样吗？是的，平装书夏天出来，包装会略有不同，还有一些小惊喜，音频是真正火起来的东西，我自己读的，我，你知道，
today but yeah I definitely want to do more and there's more stuff kind of possible adaptations from the book and amazing yeah so well I'm so pleased and I you know I could never have imagined that Kavanaugh Anthony would be so lovely and that when I messaged him he would reply absolutely we'd have such a great interview thank you yeah and review of the book here yeah so thank you for being lovely um I'm wishing you best with everything that comes next so at the moment as we record the hardback book is out but the paperback is coming out in the summer is that right yeah the paperback's out in the summer it'll be slightly differently packaged and a few little surprises and the audio is the thing that's really blown up which i read myself which i you know
上帝保佑你的耳朵，因为那是我八个小时的谈话，但嗯，音频是，是，是，也可以买到，精装书，亚马逊是，你知道，一些书店，完美。所以人们可以在Instagram上哪里关注你。所以我的Instagram是K-A-V-A-U-N-A-R-E-A-L，Kavanaugh-U-A-L。Kavanaugh-U-A-L。完美。非常感谢。给我发信息。我总是，我总是会看我的私信，给我发信息。你确实会。你很善良。非常感谢你的时间。谢谢你邀请我。这太棒了。你好，我叫维罗妮卡·卡索娃。我住在爱丁堡，我刚获得了心理健康心理学的硕士学位。
god bless your ears because it's eight hours of me talking but um the audio is is is is available too and the hardback um amazon are you know some some book shops perfect so where can people follow you on Instagram. So my Instagram is K-A-V-A-N-A-U-N-A-R-E-A-L, Kavanaugh-U-A-L. Kavanaugh-U-A-L. Perfect. Thank you so much. Message me. I'm always, I always kind of look at my DMs and message me. You do. You're very kind. Thank you very much for your time. Thank you for having me. It's been brilliant. Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a master's in
玛丽安在LinkedIn上建立联系时向我推荐了临床心理学家集体，我不能说我爱它。它是独一无二的。它就像一扇窗户，窥视着那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙事才能揭示的无形智慧。我最看重的故事中的一个共同点是富有同情心，不仅是对他人，也是对自己。此外，不要执着于成为一名心理学家，
psychology of mental health. Marion recommended me the clinical psychologist collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I not say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate, not of only with others, but with myself too. Also, not fixating on becoming a psychologist,
而是享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品出现。玛丽安，谢谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一颗真正的宝石，我认为每个有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
but enjoying life, growth and the final results will come as a by-product. Marian, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem, and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然而然地到来。玛丽安，感谢你花时间整理了所有的故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。